yo está llegó este miércoles a el
salvador como tormenta tropical incluso
después de debilitarse el centro
nacional de huracanes de estados unidos
advirtió que las inundaciones y los
deslizamientos de tierra siguen siendo
una amenaza mortal
yota ha venido azotando ciudades y
pueblos ya afectados por el paso de la
tormenta eta hace un par de semanas a
medida que se desplazaba sobre el sur de
honduras las autoridades informaron de
la desaparición de decenas de personas
el gobierno hondureño ordenó el cierre
de las carreteras hasta la mañana de
este miércoles ante el riesgo de
desbordamiento de ríos al tiempo que
abrió más de 600 refugios esto está
bastante triste temible
de miedo por aquí todo no hay por donde
paz no hay paso la gente bastante dañado
psicológicamente y no hay a dónde
agarrar la verdad aunque a su paso por
nicaragua se degradó rápidamente de
huracán categoría 4 a tormenta tropical
yota dejó seis muertos y una ola de
destrucción árboles caídos casas sin
tejados y postes de electricidad
derivados fue la tormenta más fuerte de
la que se tenga constancia en el país
estaba demasiado fuerte el viento
entonces cuando cree se entiendo mi casa
ya estaba
ya trabajas y menos viendo entonces yo
tuve que salir con medio voto mi casa se
lo llevó toda la casa yo sentía como que
venía a mirarme encima ahora me quedé
sin trastes en rocas en napa ahora soy
la calle antes de llegar a centroamérica
yo te impactó de lleno la isla
colombiana de san andrés providencia y
santa catalina un departamento que vivió
la peor tragedia de su historia
allí se reportan dos muertos el
presidente colombiano iván duque reportó
desde allí la probable destrucción del
98 por ciento de la infraestructura en
providencia